mom what are you up to oh just book
reading are you chewing the post mommy's
going a little crazy down here so I need
to get out and I know you're worried I'm
gonna go out there and kill somebody but
think about all the people I haven't
killed literally everyone in the world
except three people I just think you
should keep a low profile till we know
what's going on I'm just gonna act like
all she laughs please demure and chipper
and never had an orgasm while eating a
man's liver hmm I think our killer looks
too much like a kill room you know feels
like we copied it from a kill room
catalog
is this you guys human body parts down
network
it could be spreading a lot of people
have gone missing from Santa Clarita
lately we get rid of one cop and now you
bring another cop into our lives you're
getting more aggressive oh it's probably
yet a lot worse
I love you and we have each other
everything else we can figure out what
the [ __ ] is this I'm actually looking
forward to a day without any
life-and-death issues someday if you
have kids and you get a virus and start
killing people you'll appreciate how
well your mother and I are doing I'm
gonna take [ __ ] up dream big I don't
want to stop living just because I'm
undead [ __ ] we need to figure out what
caused this so it won't happen to anyone
else
we could save the blue Oh today's not
good what we have a lot of all in the
air this is the biggest project of our
life what good is a housing development
when armies of flesh-eating ghouls are
filling the streets we both have really
good arguments I don't think we both do
don't get me never
I'm so sorry no family is perfect
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up I'm Gary
not today
[Music]
you